Caesar has been a whirlwind what have
you learned from this experience
Love is Blind
well something fun for you I'm less
excited that works too yes
um Alexa what has made your life been it
has been absolutely incredible there's
not there's not one thing I can say
that's you know that's bad it's it's a
joy every single morning waking up with
him and it's a you know Joy going to bed
with him as well it's you know it's the
first thing I think to see in the
morning it's the last thing I see at
night and it's I can't imagine going
through this journey of life with
literally with anyone else it's the most
incredible human awesome and Colleen
how's Mary like been for you married
life has been great it has it's it was
hard like all marriages in the beginning
and on top of getting married so so soon
and how we got married
um so we had our challenges but we've
overcome them and we're better than ever
and I love him so much and yeah we're
really happy I love that oh my God and
so do you guys think your relationships
who are portrayed fairly on this show
have you guys seen the show have you do
you think it was an accurate
representation I think it was very
accurate I think that they don't show as
much Brennan is hilarious he's so funny
and I'm a lot nicer I think that they we
switched so we we very much compliment
one another and I think that um I wish I
had seen more of his goofiness that was
in it because he looks he's he's a
sweetheart but he is there's so much
more to him than just him being you know
the southern gentleman he is a he's a
naughty man so I wish they'd shown that
a little bit more
um I was very surprised that unsk did
not get married how what's going on
between you SK now what's your status
now yeah there's so much more that I
want you guys to see like our journey
has been so great up to the point of our
wedding and I'm just really excited for
everyone to experience the rest of it
with us so yay and zenib I am so happy
what you said on the altar I felt like
you just had such a growing Journey with
it in the show and like what you said I
think was all very fair and honest do
you regret anything you said or do you
wish you said it differently or timing
or anything
um I stand by everything I said
um I'm proud of myself I did have a
journey and I learned a lot about myself
I meant it when I said Cole had taught
me so much about myself I really
recognized some things I needed to work
on it's a very you know experience where
you can look inward to so I stand by
everything I said do you and Cole still
talk what's your relationship we do not
have a relationship there is no talking
probably for the best
and Nancy what about you and bartiste do
you guys have a relationship are you
talking what's going on
um no after after the wedding
um I just I couldn't I couldn't see
myself
um being around someone who had betrayed
me and left me at the altar blindsided
so
um but yeah
it was honestly a blessing looking back
at it it was something that in the
moment I was
blindly in love you know with someone
and I wanted to see the the best in him
I wanted to offer Grace for his mistakes
and he wasn't willing to sacrifice that
or make those those
um I guess compromises for for us or
um see me for the woman that I am and
thank you for saying no
I think you touch a bullet there thank
you so as a viewer I found that like
really like jealousy and insecurities
really were the driving force of of like
what tore a part of a couple would you
guys agree with that statement or would
you guys say there's anything else that
you really thought divided you as a
couple or brought you guys maybe more
together but I definitely thought those
were like the two qualities I would
definitely own up to some insecurities I
think I was definitely
um on the lookout for some words of
affirmation from Cole that I I didn't
really personally get he he would
definitely tell other people but I
didn't necessarily get so many
affirmations and now what I've been
doing last year is honestly just giving
that to myself I guess myself up so as
you should thank you thank you
you guys are all like very beautiful in
that day
thank you I feel like again the
insecurity is so hard not to be insecure
it's like a woman that's like a science
when I think like even insecurities
right like I think for me like I got to
know Raven for who she was as a person
as a friend as an independent woman so
after we left the pods after Malibu like
there was no drama like it was nothing
but love support respect for each other
and 100 you know Colleen and I too don't
have an issue we don't have a single
issue we're good we should get married
they'll always watches
2.0
and you guys really focus like on the
pods I think this season's very
different like no one really talked
about physical traits are you guys happy
that you did that or are you like upset
I am yeah yeah none of them was you know
genuine what the
[ __ ] it's like a tall skinny Ginger
like I don't know
like I don't know what I was thinking
yeah was that like weird having like a
picture of someone in your head and then
there is a true disconnect I don't I
don't know if I speak for everyone but I
could I still couldn't I was like no
like even though I didn't try to imagine
him I was like um if I closed my eyes
and I hear you I know it too but yeah
you know when you're not with them you
start picturing like what they like you
want to lay in bed with that person but
you're like what do they look like with
Brennan's like Southern drawl I just
really pictured like blonde hair blue
eyes yeah and then when he came out and
he's like a Ken doll I'm like what you
know not lucky me
oh my God and Colleen do you think Matt
is the boy version of you you said that
that was what you really wanted so yeah
no he
never stops making me laugh but also he
really at that still today he is like my
best friend that I've known for my whole
life and it was wild to have that
feeling so soon from meeting somebody
and that's why I felt so comfortable and
that's why I kept doing that smiling
because I was so happy with him and he
he got me and I got him and what's the
experience like in the pods like how
long are you guys really talking to
these people hours
[Music]
one day okay I know it looks like we
talked once and then it was it
yeah I'm not so insane okay and
sometimes it's a crazy morning date and
sometimes it's like an afternoon late
late late so and then sometimes you know
like I would date bartisan then he'd go
and date Raven but then he'd go and date
Zana so like sometimes we'd get them
back to back you know like so it was
interesting I feel like that would be
definitely the most interesting just
like dating is like your full-time job
then oh yeah forget like what
conversations you had with it you're
like wait did we talk yeah yeah that's
the worst don't don't name call don't
say oh are you yeah no don't do the same
call who did you name call I'd never
name called yeah I was like I'm gonna
wait till they say something
okay well that's all our time so thank
you guys thank you I love this season
you guys are all beautiful and all green
you guys could be Stars